in our morning rounds one surgeons
effort to save crucial time for victims
of a stroke on average a stroke kills
one American every four minutes the odds
of survival improved when emergency
treatment begins quickly and that's
because almost two million brain cells
die every minute during a stroke David
beg no met one neurosurgeon in Florida
who found a new way to rush to the
emergency room to help his patients
David good morning nor good morning and
good to see you there's just one surgeon
who operates on all of the stroke
victims at Palmetto general hospital
outside Miami this guy performs about a
hundred emergency procedures every year
and he needs to be there whenever the
call comes that means if he's with his
family on the weekend it doesn't matter
this guy feels an obligation to respond
there's a stroke now yeah having they
just announced it oh just a finally know
what it is absolutely in this case dr.
ritesh kaushal was already here at
Palmetto general hospital but he often
has to drive in to treat stroke victims
depending on the time of day his
15-minute commute can easily stretch
into 45 minutes just the amount of
damage that can happen and just about
half an hour delay was spectacular but
now damage control for his patients he
uses emergency lights on his personal
car speeding his arrival to folks like
Robert bus lo whose family dialed 911
suddenly had trouble tying his shoes and
sweeping the porch how bad was it it was
considered a fatal stroke of who wasn't
taken care of the neurosurgeon did take
care of it before bus Louie Ventoux what
was happening and he musta gotten that
very quick because the moment I got in
there I within the scanners going from
one to the other and then all of a
sudden he got it out just as he did for
the patient who arrived when we were
there kasho pulled out a tiny blood clot
like this if I did not have the light so
if it had taken me another half an hour
to get to him things would have been
very different potentially probably
would have been paralyzed on the right
side and would have never been able to
speak the reason I have absolutely no
ill effects if because you know dr.
cashel got there very very quick no
sirens though right no simons do you
like to smoke your horn oh yeah usually
if I need to
we mounted a camera inside of his car to
see how it works the lights allow him to
drive on the shoulder of the highway
around traffic backups the fire
department installed this after first
checking to make sure it was legal still
has to abide by all traffic law spray so
he has to stop at the red lights go the
speed limit he can just sort of move
through the back cover back on the
freeway as people see the vehicle coming
they usually yield it does have risks
there are accidents that occur crashes
that occur dr. Douglas Kubis of the
national association of state EMS
officials says EMS medical directors
sometimes respond to scenes with lights
and sirens on their cars but that this
is the first time he's heard of a
surgeon using emergency lights whenever
there's a jam otherwise I'd never you
dr. kaushal works 350 days last year and
he measures success by the minute what
we see is that any of these delays those
brain cells really translate to this
person being able to walk out of this
hospital on his own or go to a nursing
home and be paralyzed for the rest of
his life so health officials suggest a
best way for stroke victims to save time
is recognize the symptoms there's an
acronym fast watch for these things a
drooping face arm weakness or speech
problems and to get help as soon as
possible dr. kaushal says he's used the
lights about seven times since he
installed them in December in September
and here was a lighter moment he said to
me he said I had to talk to my wife
who's also a doctor about can I do this
and she said yeah sure just get some
extra life insurance and he did but this
is so crucial and to know that you're
having a stroke i'm a big night I mean
Victor Charlie we watched him while we
were there remove a stroke from a man's
brain and it was the size of a rice
kernel and he walked in and he couldn't
move a limb shows you right there it's
so nice to have you at the table it's so
good to be here good to be here still is
that tell you what I'm in a suit I feel
like a fish out of water so you're yeah
because you're usually you know crawling
through the snow or ain't gotta die wins
it all I'm not walking not walking it's
so good to see you guys happy Halloween
love what you can drink you feeling is
mutual about David thank you thank you